Well, good morning again, church.
Uh, my name is John, one of the pastors here.
I get the privilege of preaching most Sundays.
It's an honor to do that.
If you're new to our church, we wanna say welcome,
especially to you.
Love to meet you. Uh, come say hi to us.
There's a new here area out there as well.
I just want to get to know you
as best we can help you connect here, uh, in those ways.
And as always, if you're here all the time,
call Henderson Hills home.
It's great to see you as well. We love you.
Uh, let's get to worship together every week.
What a privilege. And as we continue our journey
through the Old Testament book of one Samuel,
lemme invite you to take your copy of it
and turn to one Samuel Chapter 16 today, one Samuel 16 is
where we're gonna be in our study today,
asking God to work through his word to transform us.
One Samuel 16. As you turn there, think about this.
Maybe you've heard the phrase,
don't judge a book by its cover.
Probably most of us have.
Maybe your grandma said that growing up a lot. I don't know.
But it's a truism that points to the fact
that you shouldn't just look at the outside,
what you see initially of a person.
You need to look deeper and beyond the surface
into somebody's life.
We don't know the source of that,
but lemme give you one possible source.
It's from our text actually today, one Samuel 16,
verse seven, man looks on the outward appearance,
but the Lord looks at the heart,
man looks on the outward appearance,
but the Lord looks on the heart.
Maybe that's the source, maybe not.
But what we've learned as we've walked
through the first half of this book of First Samuel, is
that the first king of Israel, Saul, we know now
that his heart was not in it.
He looked the part, but on the inside,
his heart was not in it.
And because his heart was not toward the Lord,
God rejected him as the king
because what God wanted, we see it there in chapter 16,
verse seven, but, but we also saw it back in
chapter 13, verse 14.
What God wanted was that the Lord had sought out a man
after his own heart.
Like more than sacrifices, more than religious actions.
What God wanted was a person's heart.
God wants someone who
is oriented toward him.
He wants someone who is seeking to obey him.
Because if you remember, that was the base level
for the kings of Israel.
Their heart was to be oriented towards God.
Their heart was to be wanting to obey God.
It wouldn't work any other way.
They could be a king, but it wouldn't actually work.
The narrative today, chapter 16, will show us
how God sought out Saul's replacement.
How God sought a man known for pursuing
God's heart, for leading
others to do the same.
That that's what God was wil for.
That's what God was wanting.
And so we'll see that today in First Samuel 16.
Now, if you're familiar with your Bible at all,
you might be aware that chapter 17 is the familiar David
and Goliath narrative.
We're actually gonna take a break after today
and we'll pick back up with that story.
First Samuel 17, after the first of the year,
we're gonna do some Christmas things here in between.
But first Samuel 17 is David and Goliath.
Now there's a debate when you study the research
about this passage.
There's a debate about which chapter
in chronological order actually happened.
First, some people would say that chapter 17, David
and Goliath was actually the first thing that happened.
And then what we'll see today in chapter 16,
where David is anointed as king
and David is entering into Saul's service.
That actually happened after.
There's some convincing arguments to that.
I don't know exactly,
but the question would be is why
would they have reversed it?
Why would the author narrator have reversed
these two events?
Why did he put this part first
where David will will show up on the scene?
David will serve in salt. Like why that?
Because it highlights how important it was that God was
with David, because that
is the marker of David's life.
The whole journey through first
and second Samuel we'll see is that David was marked
by the presence of God his entire life,
which also, by the way, sets up a contrast here with Saul.
It's been the whole book, but this especially will show
us that contrast.
So whether it happened one way
or the other, you'll see why it happened in
the text this way.
So let's look back historically.
First I wanna read the whole of chapter 16
because it helps us understand
how this whole thing works out together.
But as I read, we finally meet a new character
that we've been waiting for the whole time.
You'll see it here, first Samuel chapter 16.
The Lord said to Samuel,
how long will you grieve over Saul since I've rejected him
from being king over Israel?
That happened in chapter 15 right
before this, fill your horn with oil
and go, I'll send you to Jesse the Bethlehemite for I've
provided for myself a king among his sons.
And Samuel said, how can I go if Saul
hears that he'll kill me?
The Lord said, take a heifer with you
and say, I've come to sacrifice to the Lord.
Invite Jesse to the sacrifice
and I'll show you what you shall do.
You shall anoint for me him whom I declare to you.
So Samuel did what the Lord commanded came to Bethlehem.
The elders of the city came to meet him, trembling
and saiddo, you come peaceably
'cause he could have been bringing judgment.
And he said, peaceably, I've come to sacrifice to the Lord.
Consecrate yourselves. Come with me to the sacrifice.
He consecrated. Jesse
and his sons invited them to the sacrifice.
And when they came, he looked on Elia,
that was Jesse's oldest son.
He looked on Elia and thought, well,
surely the Lord's anointed us before him.
But the Lord said to Samuel, do not look on his appearance
or on the height of his stature because I've rejected him.
For the Lord sees not
as man sees man looks on the outward appearance,
but the Lord looks on the heart.
Then Jesse called a beda his second son
and made him pass before Samuel.
And he said, neither has the Lord chosen this one.
And then Jesse made Shama, the third son passed by
and he said, neither has the Lord chosen this one.
And Jesse made seven of his sons pass before Samuel
and Samuel said to Jesse, the Lord has not chosen these.
And Samuel said to Jesse, are all your sons here?
And he said, well, there remains the youngest
that can also be translated smallest,
but behold, he is keeping the sheep.
Samuel said to Jesse, send and get him.
We will not sit down until he comes here.
And he sent and brought him in.
Now he was ruddy, reddish, colored, and had beautiful eyes
and was handsome.
And the Lord said, arise, anoint him for this is he.
Samuel took the horn of oil
and anointed him in the midst of his brothers.
And the spirit of the Lord rushed upon David
from that day forward.
And Samuel Rose up and went to Rama.
Now, verse 14, now the spirit of the Lord departed from Saul
and a harmful spirit from the Lord tormented him.
And Saul's servants said to him, behold,
now a harmful spirit from God is tormenting you.
Let our Lord now command your servants who are
before you to seek out a man
who is skillful in playing the liar or the harp.
And when the harmful spirit from God is
upon you, he'll play it.
You'll be well. So Saul said to his servants, provide
for me a man who can play well and bring him to me.
And one of the young men answered.
Behold, I've seen a son of Jesse,
the Bethlehemite who's skillful in playing a man of valor,
man of war, prudent in speech, a man of good presence,
and the Lord is with him.
Therefore, Saul sent messenger to Jesse, said,
send me David, your son who's with the sheep.
Jesse took a donkey laden with bread and a skin of wine.
A young goat sent them by David to his, by David,
his son to Saul.
David came to Saul, entered his service.
Saul loved him greatly and he became his armor bearer.
And Saul sent to Jesse saying,
let David remain in my service.
He's found favor in my sight.
Whenever the harmful spirit from God was upon Saul,
David took the liar and played it with his hand.
And Saul was refreshed, was well.
The harmful spirit departed from him.
God, there is a lot here.
But we know, Lord, it's your word
and you want to speak to us through it.
Show us something clearly today that we need
to know about you, that we need to know about ourselves,
that we need to know about the world.
God, we want to be more like you.
Jesus, help us through your word.
Holy spirit, you have to work
or this will be fruitless today.
Speak to us in Jesus authority we pray. Amen.
So again, one of the key points highlighted here,
you saw it in the narrative, was
that God gave his spirit to David.
That's pretty much the main point
of the first half at least.
But God gave his spirit to David.
'cause if you remember, the presence
of God was the key distinguishing mark
for the kings of Israel.
That was to be primary. He God was to be primary in
that king's life.
And we'll deal with Saul later. We'll come back to that.
But but the first half of the chapter, the aim of it is
to highlight that it was God who selected David
and that God was with David.
Right? That's the whole point here is it's showing us
that David is now the one.
But it's such an interesting narrative, isn't it?
Because you, you track through this
and it takes a long time.
Just imagine you were reading this for the first time,
know nothing else about it.
You're reading through it
and it takes you a long time to discover who
that new king finally will be, right?
'cause Samuel, he had to go to this back woods,
forgotten town named Bethlehem.
He had to deal with the elders who were afraid
of him to begin with.
And then he had to go through this parade of seven
of Jesse's sons, one after another.
Like it, it feels like some kind of pageant here
or something where, where it's like they got a talent
portion and an interview portion, which by the way,
if it's an interview portion, he answered that question.
Perfect date with April 25th, right? That's a guarantee.
Like 20 of you have seen that movie. Okay, sorry.
Um, anyway, but those seven
that he tracked through, they were all in.
Oh, so they had to go find the runt
of the litter out there with the sheep.
But even then they bring that kid in
and even then, we don't know his name.
We don't even know if he's a kid
or if he's old, we don't know.
But even then, we don't know his name till the whole process
is finally completed.
They're anointed him and all this stuff happening.
And we don't know it until the very end.
But that was intentional because the author
wanted to keep the reader's attention on
what was most important here.
God's presence was with him. That was critical.
If they would've said David from the very beginning,
most people reading this later would've had all the things
about David in their mind.
They would've not known anything other
than what they knew then.
This is intentional. God's presence is primary.
But what I want us to notice here
as we think about God's presence,
that this is highlighting David as the new King.
Notice how clearly God makes the point that this selection
of David as the new king
was completely contrary to circumstances.
Like completely contrary to every circumstance.
You can imagine that they would've selected a king by
again, this forgotten, sleepy town,
this less than prominent family within that forgotten town.
And then the youngest son,
or at least the smallest son
who wasn't even considered an option by his dad.
You notice that Samuel goes to Jesse,
Hey Jesse, bring your sons in.
We're gonna pick a king. Okay, great. Here are my sons.
No, you got any more?
Oh yeah, I remember we got his son out in the
sheep fold, right?
Like, I forgot we,
so it's like not even an op didn't even
bring him in to begin with.
That's how forgotten. That's how contrary
to the circumstances it was.
But again, that was intentional by God to prove to us
that it's not about the way we see things,
it's about the way God sees things.
It's exactly what God said to Samuel.
Jesse parades his first son by him.
Verse seven, what did it say?
God says, do not look at his appearance
or on the height of his stature because I've rejected him.
For the Lord sees not as man sees,
man looks on the outward appearance,
but the Lord looks on the heart.
And this contrast between Saul and David
and the way the people work, the way God works,
it's even more clear when you think back to
how Saul was identified
as he was anointed as the king.
You remember that? What'd they say?
He's taller than everybody else.
That's, that's it. Like, yeah, that's pretty much it.
He was head and shoulders taller than everybody.
So they're like, that's the king right there. We know it.
What? That doesn't make any sense, right?
It'd be like if you would call a pastor to a church just
because you like listening to his voice.
Don't, I don't care what he says,
I don't care his character.
I love listening to his like that. That doesn't fly right?
But that's what they did.
Remember what they were wanting a king
for in the first place?
They wanted a king because they were afraid
and they wanted to be like everybody else.
They wanted somebody to lead him into battle.
So the biggest, tallest, strongest guy made sense.
But how did that work out for him?
But you see that that was the drive was
to look at the way we think it should go.
This is, this has gotta be the way it works.
Look, he's bigger and taller. He's stronger.
He's gonna be our victor.
But notice who God picked.
It was David who was anointed king.
It was David who was given God's presence
contrary to his size, contrary to his birth order,
contrary to the fact that Saul is still the
king at this moment.
David is anointed King. David is given God's presence.
So why was David anointed?
Why did God look at all
of this other stuff, all these other people?
Why did God say, yep, David is the one.
It's because of David's commitment,
because of David's commitment to the Lord.
It's the sole reason God said. David is the one again.
Verse seven. What did God say there?
Man looks on the outward appearance,
but the Lord looks on the heart.
In other words, God is not concerned about the container.
Here's what I mean by that. He, he's not worried about
what the outside, what the vessel,
what the container looks like.
He's way more concerned about what's on the inside of
that container, right?
This is all over Second Corinthians chapter four when Paul
talks about we are treasure.
We have treasure in jars of clay like this
unassuming really kind
of fragile weird jar.
It doesn't matter what that thing's like,
because what matters is what's on the
inside of that, of that jar.
The treasure inside the jar of clay.
God's not worried about the container.
He doesn't really care about the the authority or
or background or propensity towards
this or abilities here and there.
It doesn't, it's not a big deal to him.
He's much more worried about what's on the inside.
Because if you remember what we saw last week with Saul,
we saw that it is, even if you try
to dress up the container, you try
to wash it, you try to cover it, you try
to make it look pretty, you religiously cover up
the blemishes on it.
You try to do anything that's going
to make other people feel like it's beautiful,
it, it will not work.
God sees right through it. God sees that
that container is actually empty.
He wants what's on the inside more than on the outside.
And with Saul, because he was living like that,
God rejected him because of it.
Again, what was the Lord looking for?
A man after his own heart.
And he found that man in David.
David wasn't perfect, but David wanted the Lord.
David wrote most of the Psalms, majority of the Psalms.
Lemme just give you one example. Psalm 63 verse one.
He says, oh God, you are my God, earnestly,
deeply, strongly.
I seek you my soul thirsts for you.
My flesh faints for you as in a dry
and weary land where there is no water.
You see that again, David wasn't perfect.
We'll look over the next couple months about David
that he failed some major faith tests in his life.
But what we also learn about David is that he was repentant.
He was turning back to God when he did get off track
because he knew God and he longed for God.
He loved God because God had loved him first.
God anointed him.
God gave him his presence
because of David's commitment to him.
He knew this was a man after his own heart.
But it wasn't just for David,
it was also God anointed David as the king.
Not just because of his commitment.
God anointed David as the king
because of his purposes in David's life.
For God's purposes,
he anointed David in history in the world in David's life.
In all that God anointed David, God brought all this
because of his purposes.
In the end
I I said that David was anointed by God.
That doesn't mean that God approved of everything David did.
But what we see is that God clearly had a massive
and eternal purpose for David, for David's life
to lead God's people in a more godly way than Saul did,
to bring about prosperity and protection
and safety more than any other king did.
And eventually one of the purposes of David's anointing
as king was to be the line through which the king
of kings would eventually come.
That son of David referenced in the New Testament,
the God man himself, Jesus Christ.
See, that was one of the primary reasons that David became
the king, was to begin the lineage
through which Jesus would eventually come.
What a purpose for a seemingly insignificant man
from Bethlehem, right?
God gave David his spirit.
Now, I've mentioned this already a number of times today
and throughout the series that that's first Samuel
and especially the rest of it from this point forward is
really an extended contrast between Saul and David.
It just sets them up as opposites and how to respond to God.
And it becomes abundantly clear,
even right here at the start of their relationship.
So verse 13, right?
God gave his spirit, the spirit
of the Lord rushed upon David.
From that day forward, we see it abundantly clear.
God gave his spirit to David.
But immediately next in verse 14,
the very next verse, what happened?
God removed his spirit from Saul.
He had given his spirit to David.
And the next verse, God removed his spirit
from Saul like these two verses,
you can't get any more different.
You can't get any more final about
how God had given his spirit to David
and taken his spirit away from Saul.
It's final now that this is what God was doing.
He'd rejected Saul from being the king
and he'd anointed David as the new King
and the rest of the chapter nearly overemphasizes
what God was doing in replacing Saul, right?
You see this, this interaction between this evil spirit
and the good spirit and David and Saul
and David's, this well-known man
and Saul is already over here in a really bad place
and how they interact together, it's nearly showing us
to an over extent what God is doing
to replace Saul with David.
Again, Saul's gonna remain in the position of King
until his death at the end of the book.
But already this move has happened towards David.
Now we've shown this chart throughout the series already
and you can see it where we're beginning to see the decline
of Saul's popularity
and David now ascending in popularity,
which will only cross over further and further.
And that tension between the two of them only grows
as we move forward in the book.
And what we'll come to find out is that Saul is very jealous
that God is now with David and not with him.
And we'll see where that ends up throughout the book.
So that's what was happening back then in chapter 16.
That's what historically happened.
Whether it was first or second between David
and Goliath, we don't know officially, but,
but that's what happened here to highlight David having
received God's spirit and anointing as king.
But what does that all mean for us today currently?
Like how, how does that come forward to today?
'cause we're not dealing with Kings,
we're not dealing with Saul and David.
Okay? What do we take from this?
Here are a couple principles
that we can glean from this today.
Here's the first one. We need to remember
that God sees things differently.
This should be just a great foundational truth for us
to remember in our lives.
God sees things differently than we do.
Remember the The People's Choice Awards back then Saul won
that one, right?
The people's choice was Saul.
They picked him because he's tall.
I can't keep rhyming that. I don't know.
I was about to go somewhere with that,
but I couldn't think quick enough.
But based on his stature, that's what they picked him like.
And we saw how that ended up. It didn't go well.
The people's choice was Saul, but God's choice.
David was based on something totally different,
completely different stipulation,
completely different process and context.
But what that reveals, this is so interesting,
this reveals this theme that is all over God's word.
Where God chooses the one who might
otherwise have been passed over.
Just think about the stories, you know, right?
Jacob and Esau, the older son
would one day serve the younger son you, you think about
Joseph amongst his brothers, one
of the young ones like how did, why did he get picked?
You think of Baron Sarah,
90 years old, God blesses her with the ability
to have the chosen son.
Isaac, even in the book
we're studying, you remember back to the beginning,
Hannah, Hannah's barren.
Hannah's unable to have children.
Hannah's been praying, asking God, wanting, longing.
And God blesses her with a son named Samuel
who turns into Samuel here, right?
And then now David, the runt of the litter,
no other circumstance says this guy should be the king.
God picks him over the seven other sons who look the part.
And so with families, God works this out.
God often does things that don't fit.
He sees things differently. But it's not just with families.
We see it in God choosing Israel itself.
Listen to this. This is Deuteronomy chapter seven,
verses six through eight.
This is as the people are exiting Egypt,
listen to God say this for you are a people holy
to the Lord your God.
The Lord your God has chosen you to be a people
for his treasured possession out of all the peoples
who were on the face of the earth.
But it was not because you were more in
number than any other people.
That the Lord set his love on you
and chose you for you are actually the
fewest of all peoples.
But it is He chose because the Lord loves you
and is keeping the oath that he swore to your fathers,
that the Lord has brought you out with a mighty hand
and redeemed you from the house of slavery, from the house
of Pharaoh king of Egypt.
You see that God chose them for their weakness.
Why? Same reason He chooses
people like you and me today.
This is what Paul, the Apostle Paul wrote
to the church in Corinth.
First Corinthians chapter one verse 26,
for Consider your calling Brothers, not many
of you were wise according to worldly standards.
Not many were powerful. Not many were of noble birth.
But God chose what is foolish in the world
to shame the wise.
God chose what is weak in the world to shame the strong
God chose what is low despised in the world.
Even things that are not to bring to nothing.
Things that are so that, so that
no human being might boast in the presence of God.
And because of him, you are in Christ
Jesus who became to us.
Wisdom from God. Righteousness, sanctification, redemption.
So that as it is written, let the one
who boasts boast in the Lord.
You see that God chooses the weak
so he can show off his power through them.
God sees things differently than we do.
'cause remember, David's an unlikely candidate.
He was cute, but he was forgotten.
He was out in the field, a lowly shepherd,
and he was in an undistinguished family,
in a forgotten town, unimportant town.
And as humans, we are so prone to look for the obvious
to say, well, that guy looks the part, he must be the one.
This guy over here, he's worth nothing.
Let's forget about him. That's what we are prone to do.
But God's ways are not our ways.
Look past the cover of the book, right?
Because that's the way God looks.
God does not look at the outside, he looks at the inside.
So lemme give you two applications,
two base level applications.
First, listen, never,
never feel unimportant in the eyes of the Lord.
You should never, no matter who you are,
you should never feel unimportant in the eyes of the Lord.
I know your mind is thinking,
but I'm not prominent, I'm not talented, I'm not wealthy.
I don't have a prominent position.
Whatever it is you're thinking,
the enemy's tossing in your brain trying to get you to say,
well no, you're really not that important.
Look, you don't stand up on the stage and do anything.
You're not. You're not that important.
Listen, one Corinthians one, what did it say?
He gets more glory.
When someone is not wise, according
to the world standards, he gets more glory.
When someone does not have worldly power out there
that they can leverage, he gets more glory for that.
Now listen, God might have made you talented.
God might have made you strong.
God might have given you a prominent position.
It's not wrong to have those things.
He says Not many of you are wise, like
so somebody's gonna be wise.
God gifts us in different ways. That's absolutely true.
But if you are talented, wealthy,
you have a prominent position, whatever it is,
if you are any those things, be careful
because it is really, really easy to trust in yourself,
to boast in yourself.
And lemme tell you that's that's my story
for a good chunk of my life.
Like I acted for so long as if the abilities that I had,
I somehow deserved them.
And and I, I acted as if like they weren't God's gift, but,
but I just kind of created them somehow.
And you know what that led to?
It led to a lot of pride, a lot of self-sufficiency
and self-reliance.
It certainly did not lead to boasting in the Lord,
boasting in myself.
We must not forget that everything we have is from Him.
Everything we have, every ability you have,
any resources, you have any position or family
or whatever you have, it is all from the Lord's hand.
You did not choose any of that.
God did this for no, but I made the money.
No, God gave you the ability
to think to make the money right?
So you understand God gave you, this is all from his hand
and he has a purpose to glorify His name through
what you can do, also through
what you can't do to glorify his name
through doing something you can't do on your own.
And it takes him to do it in you. That is a pointer.
All of it is a pointer to him.
So do not feel unimportant in the eyes of the Lord.
He does not see things the way everybody else sees them.
But here's what that means. We should do.
We must prioritize what's on the inside.
We must prioritize the heart.
If God sees things differently than the way the world sees
them, then we better prioritize what he sees
as the most important, our relationship with him.
Prioritize that above the outside.
'cause just think about, think about how much money we spend
on the containers of our lives,
plastic surgery, new cars,
Instagram worthy vacations,
all to polish the container of our lives
so that people think we're better than we actually are.
Are we putting an even higher value than all
of those things on what's inside our hearts?
On our hearts, our relationship with him?
Are we, are we prioritizing how we stand with him?
Where we stand with him, how we're pursuing him?
Are we doing anything like that?
Or are we so focused on the container
and what people think about us
and what we look like to other people
that we forget what's most important to God?
That's what he cares about the most.
He says it explicitly right here.
Even more hear me even more than religious activities.
That was Saul sacrificing, doing the right things,
saying the right things, showing up at church like you have
it all together, giving, serving all whatever it is
to polish the container.
But God's more focused on what's in here
and he sees right through it that
that container might be empty.
He wants your heart. He sees things differently.
He wants your heart. So what do we do with that?
Let's treat each other differently
because that's what God prioritizes,
not what's on the outside.
We give a lot of prominence.
We give a lot of deference to people who have a lot of this
or a lot of that, or are able to do this.
And like, that's not the way God works.
Let's not look to the outside first.
Let's look on what's on the inside first
and then as a result of that in our own lives,
let's live our lives differently.
Because our hearts are our priority.
The focus is on God's presence, his his relationship
with us first and foremost, from the inside out.
Let's live differently as a result of what he's done.
So that's the first principle. God sees things differently.
The second principle here though is similar,
that we must not neglect it from chapter 16.
The truth is that God will accomplish his purposes.
God's gonna do his work. God will accomplish his purposes.
The theological word for that is sovereignty.
He's in charge. We cannot stop or thwart his work.
He will accomplish it.
One Samuel shows us that, that God does his work through
whatever, through people who obey him.
But God also works through people who disobey him.
God works through godly and ungodly people making good
and bad decisions.
He does it. He works it out.
He's going to accomplish his purposes.
But even further than that,
how he's gonna do it is he will put people in situations
that he never, that we never could have expected
God will accomplish by putting people in positions
to bring about what he desires in the world.
Just think about David. Do you think David is sitting out in
the field strumming his harp with the sheep
and he's sitting there dreaming like, you know,
I can't wait till someday that I'm
serving in the king's court.
I'm gonna kill a giant. I'm going to be the king one day.
He has no clue that that's coming.
His heart was just saying, God, I'm yours. I'll do whatever.
I'm for you. I'm with you. Here we go. I'm gonna serve.
I'm gonna do a thing. I'm gonna be what I need
to be on the inside.
That's it. And then God put him in a position to accomplish
God's purposes.
That's what made the difference. God's presence.
That's what's clear. God's presence is
what made the difference.
Whatever God had Desi assigned David to do,
it would only work by God's power through God's presence.
David couldn't do this on his own.
He couldn't have tried to manipulate his way to the throne.
It was only God.
We'll see next week that show up really clearly.
Next chapter. But listen, it's not just for David.
It's the same for you and me. It's the same for our church.
God will accomplish his mission, his purpose in the world.
We don't have to worry about that.
We don't have to worry about tomorrow what's
going on in the news.
We don't have to worry about death even.
We know God's gonna accomplish all
he's promised to do in His word.
He's good on it. We don't have to worry about it.
But if we want to participate in it,
Not just let it happen and God has to work around us,
God does things on his own like we don't, he'll do it.
But if we wanna participate in the blessing of being a part
of his mission and purpose in the world, we have to be
desperately dependent upon it.
We must have hearts solely focused on the Lord, looking
to His spirit inside us as our leader, as our power.
'cause here's what God says, one
of my favorite verses, Zechariah four, six.
It says, not by might nor by power,
but by my spirit says the Lord of hosts.
Let we modernize that, not by talent, not
by ability, not by wealth, not by resources, not
by prominence, not by reputation, not by influence,
but by my spirit says the Lord of hosts.
That's how he works. And so are you willing,
church are, are you willing
to give him your all
and watch him do what he does with your life? When you
Do that, I say, God, I'm yours.
I'm open. I'm willing. And he will do something with it
by his presence in you, meaning his power in you
to do something you could never have imagined on your own.
Yes, you.
What's our responsibility is to position
our hearts, our lives to be usable.
Containers. He doesn't care if it's clay
or if it's silver, or if it's gold.
He doesn't care. Is it usable?
That's what he cares about. God, make me a usable vessel.
That's a great prayer to pray.